pour raphaël qui est en cinquième
secondaire l'école et terminer les
vacances ont commencé même s'il reste
encore cinq semaines de cours en ligne
bachy que j'ai un cours de main mais je
suis pas non ça ne pourrait-on
n'entendent pas vraiment je fais pas des
trucs d'école pascal j'ai d'autres
occupations plus proche puis plus
attrayant d'affaires après deux mois la
maison sans travaux scolaires sans
nouvelles parfois des professeurs
beaucoup d'adolescents comme lui sont
démotivés
elle est découragée 0 motivation de
faire ces travaux de de faire des
rencontres avec ses professeurs en ce
moment et si des travaux académiques en
fait peur puis le cette semaine on a
commencé à voir des appels des
professeurs des tra ou des courriers les
professeurs pour des travaux puis le
c'était une fin de non recevoir au cours
des dernières semaines alors que les
écoles secondaires étaient fermés
plusieurs jeunes ont commencé à
travailler dans des commerces essentiels
comme ici à laval des jeunes comme cal
antoine qui gagnent de l'argent qu'ils
n'ont plus vraiment goût d'étudier
j'ai des 35 heures même plus l'effort
tout dépendant commencé surcharger la
job je n'avais pas beaucoup d'études je
me suis dit que c'était un peu les
vacances on ne peut pas travailler à
faire c'était fini l'année je suis
décidé de travailler le milieu mais j'ai
su que lire travaux allaient recommencer
ça m'a un peu surpris dans les écoles
secondaires de laval les directions les
enseignants sont inquiet pour les jeunes
3e 4e 5e secondaire la hausse et ses
locks il plus critique pour la
persévérance scolaire puis ces deux
qu'on a besoin le pur pour faire rouler
ses services essentiels louf
donc je souhaite c'est plus motivant de
travailler que de d'ordonner faire
certains travaux qui vont peut-être bon
compte et peut compter on ne sait pas
encore beaucoup sentir peut-être que ils
se sont fait abandonné par par l'école
n'est pas le système du wihrel parce que
dans le fond avec le privé qui ont
commencé dès le départ la avec le lol
l'enseignement distance le lien lyon
garder la motivation des enfants dans
certaines classes virtuelles de laval
seulement le quart des élèves sont
présents
ce professeur voit bien la démotivation
des jeunes seulement 25 de ses 160
élèves assistent à ces cours en ligne
la grosse problématique à laquelle fait
face en ce moment là c'est vraiment là
les élèves qui travaillent
à temps plein qui font du 40 ans mais
n'est plus le cas on appelle les parents
souvent semaine les parents qui vont
maintenant le taux de décrochage
scolaire à laval est d'environ 22% dans
les écoles plusieurs craignent que la
crise fasse grimper surtout c'est le
début mais le gros du décrochage
s'arrête vraiment l'automne prochain si
son contenu à l'enseignement à distance
jamais de lien avec les élèves
ça va on entrevoit vraiment le sceau de
mac a trait à cesson pour amélia qui
tente de terminer ses études secondaires
difficile de faire l'école à distance si
tu peux pas les bons l'épreuve quand tu
veux fauquette trajectoire même pour tu
te répondre j'essaie de comprendre mais
c'est dur quand ta propre étoile un défi
pour les enseignants du secondaire qui
devront faire des pieds et des mains
pour garder les élèves motivés que ce
soit sur les bancs d'école ou encore
devant leur ordinateur à la maison ici
jean philippe robien radio-canada laval